it doesn't work that well
reading with it yet but fur is still her favorite activity in her after-school care center
in
washington dc
3 but then comes the story about
the moon the chapter about the moon will
probably not be read by the seven-year-old as soon
as the place could
shutting down there is
no more money from the government because of the shutdown
rené wallis manages the after-school care program and
organizes the financing a
large part of it public funds
she has just found out that there is even less money
than she had hoped for
a quick solution is not in sight
rené is  desperate
it's about the kids and the
staff they have bills to
pay and the kids' families
rely on us it hits so
many people and i just have no
control over it
just like the 800,000
or so government workers who the state can't pay or the tourists
standing in front of closed national parks
and museums
they are already  sad that we can't go in that's
why we're here
it's a pity that the historical
museum can't visit but it's even
worse for the
back in day care rené visits the children
many students come from difficult
backgrounds have learning problems the
frustrating management the subsidies
are  approved long ago but the state
cannot pay them out
we wanted to do a performance in a
hall but we can no
longer offer it and so we are staying here too
the curriculum has been changed and to
save money we are buying cheaper
teaching material that is not good but
the worst thing for me l  and her
adoptive mother would of course be the
complete closure an alternative to
this after-school care center if you don't have the
quarreling parties have to come to an
agreement in the budget dispute so that
mitchell can continue to
read her favorite stories